[Musique]
bonjour François Bayrou bonjour les
électeurs italiens viennent de porter la
candidate de l'extrême droite Georges
jameloni en tête des élections
législatives hier c'est donc elle qui
selon toute vraisemblance va diriger le
prochain gouvernement du troisième pays
de l'Europe qu'elle doit être la
position de la France
de bord la France est co signataire des
traités qui ont fondé l'Union européenne
ces traités ont un aspect
diplomatique d'aspect économique
commerciale et un aspect des droits
fondamentaux et donc la France est
co-responsable du respect par quelques
gouvernements que ce soit des droits
fondamentaux y compris par exemple de
l'IVG si jamais leur mettait en cause
vous avez entendu la première ministre a
dit que évidemment c'était
forcément une préoccupation le vous
sentez bien le l'espèce de vague de
dérive qui existe dans toute l'Europe on
vient de voir la Suède la Suède le
temple de la social-démocratie qui vient
de choisir un gouvernement non pas
d'extrême droite mais à la tête d'une
coalition dans laquelle et l'extrême
droite alors que en Italie c'est
différent c'est l'extrême droite qui est
à la tête de la coalition mais il vient
de faire ce choix je crois qu'il y a une
très grande inquiétude
les peuples et à laquelle il faut
répondre une inquiétude qui tient aux
questions d'identité de leur identité
et une inquiétude qui tient aussi aux
difficultés que la démocratie danse et
structure et danser mode de décision
dans le même dire dont elle fonctionne
peut répondre aux attentes qui sont
parfois brûlantes des peuples je suis
persuadé qu'on peut trouver le moyen
c'est le c'est le sens de mon engagement
je suis persuadé qu'on peut trouver le
moyen de gouverner avec les peuples vous
voulez dire mais il faut pour ça que la
réfondation est une réponse à l'extrême
droite
c'est l'intuition du président de la
République c'est lui qui a voulu ça
et je crois qu'il y a dans cette
intuition quelque chose d'absolument
juste le
les institutions ne suffisent pas pour
prendre en charge les attentes profondes
des peuples des citoyens des citoyens la
communauté des citoyens
ça suffit pas on sait pas très bien
faire fonctionner cette ces capteurs ces
antennes que doivent être qui doivent
être les élus et après se transformer en
décisionnaire c'est pas très bien le
faire fonctionner ça prend un temps
infini l'administration est évidemment
plus beaucoup plus lente à bouger que
les décisions politiques elles-mêmes et
cette inquiétude là
il est juste qu'elle soit prise en
compte par des démarches nouvelles et le
Conseil national de la refondation le
CNR que le Président de la République a
voulu dans laquelle François
c'est une réponse mais c'est une réponse
vous voyez bien
comme elle est pensée c'est une réponse
qui s'adresse à l'ensemble de la
communauté des citoyens et pas seulement
aux institutions
en Italie cette union des droites est-ce
qu'elle est possible en France ce que
vous craignez et qu'elle arrive en
France et donc qu'Emmanuel Macron soit
succédé de
Marine Le Pen on disait ces derniers
jours c'est-à-dire le dernier président
avant le saut dans le vide excusez-moi
je moi je n'ai peur de rien je n'ai pas
peur le le la peur est un mode de
fonctionnement disant j'ai peur de ceci
ou j'ai peur de cela c'est pas mon
manque de fonctionnement mais ça peut
tout à fait arriver ça peut tout à fait
arriver et ça sera quelque chose
d'extrêmement négatif jamais jamais dans
l'histoire et jamais dans l'histoire des
peuples une orientation extrémiste n'a
apporté du bien-être du bonheur et
de l'épan malheureusement à un peuple
jamais la seule chose qui apporte de
l'épanouissement à un peuple c'est des
projets et des réponses équilibrées
équilibrer et sensible il faut il faut
les deux des projets équilibrés et de la
sensibilité pour savoir ce que les
concitoyens ressentent profondément
à titre individuel personnel en famille
et ce qu'il ressentent en tant que
peuple ce qui n'est pas tout à fait la
même chose à mon avis Julien
on va parler des retraites dans quelques
minutes je dois d'abord qu'on s'arrête
sur les affaires qui sont en train de
secouer plusieurs partis politiques le
dernier élément c'est la démission ce
matin de Julien Bayou qui annonce qu'il
rend sa casquette de patron des verres
Julien Bayou accusé par une ex-compagne
de comportement de violence
psychologique sans dépôt de plainte sans
main courante sans même qu'il ait été
pour l'instant entendu par la commission
interne des écologistes tout comme
d'ailleurs son ex-compagne est-ce que
pour vous c'est la bonne décision qui a
été prise et surtout qu'elle doit être
la règle dans les parties alors il y a
beaucoup de questions dans votre
question
si quelqu'un s'est rendu coupable de ces
de ces pressions de ces prises en otages
de dont on parle
alors il est normal que les conclusions
on soit tirées parce que il y a dans la
fonction politique quelque chose qui est
aussi d'exemplarité qui doit le
déterminer première chose je veux
deuxièmement je ne connais rien de cette
affaire et apparemment vous non plus
personne
n'en sait rien alors le procédé qui
consiste à aller sur un plateau de
télévision pour mettre en accusation
quelqu'un de son propre parti alors que
on a aucun élément de preuve
il y a quelque chose de
d'inquiétant dans tout ça cloué au
pylori
jeté à la vindique sur la place publique
et quelqu'un qui de surcroît de son
propre parti comme s'il y avait une
entreprise de au fond de
une entreprise
robespierreiste comme on aurait dit à la
révolution aux françaises de tête une
entreprise de terreur alors oui je pense
que
il y a là dans la société médiatique et
politique française quelque chose qui va
dans une direction très inquiétante et
donc de ce point de vue là mais
troisième observation quand on est mis
en cause publiquement que chaque fois
que vous apparaissez sur un écran les
accusations se pointent vers vous pour
quelque chose dont apparemment même vous
ne savez pas de quoi il s'agit alors
vous ne vous êtes en effet obligé de de
prendre des précautions pour que votre
fonction puisse continuer à être exercée
vous voyez que ça n'est pas simple et
c'est à beaucoup d'égards inquiétants
que ce grand déballage public sur fond
de de
d'affrontement homme-femme on va faire
je trouve ça inquiétant
le sujet complexe sur lequel on va
prendre encore un petit peu de temps si
vous le permettez je vais laisser passer
le fil info à 8h40 on va poursuivre avec
vous françois Bayrou dans un instant
Kevin dufresh tout d'abord
l'extrême droite vers la majorité
absolue dans les deux chambres en Italie
large victoire de la coalition
nationaliste aux élections législatives
avec 43% des voix selon les résultats
partielles Georgia mélodie devrait
diriger le prochain gouvernement la
réforme des retraités prioritaires les
modélisabeth borne ce matin invité de
BFM TV elle confirme qu'il y aura un
décalage de l'âge de départ à la
retraite sur la méthode ce sera décidé
d'ici la fin de semaine dit la première
ministre après des accusations de
violence psychologiques d'une de ses
ex-compagnent relayées par Sandrine
Rousseau Julien Bayou quitte ses
fonctions chez les écolos dans un
communiqué il dit restait député mais
quitte ses postes de secrétaire national
du Parti et de co-président du groupe à
l'Assemblée nationale un crash test
interstellaire la nuit prochaine la
sonde américaine dark va s'écraser sur
un astéroïde à 11 millions de kilomètres
pour tenter de dévier sa trajectoire
objective apprendre à défendre notre
planète d'une éventuelle collision avec
un astéroïde similaire à l'avenir
France Info
[Musique]
le 8 30 France Info Salia brachiha Mark
Forever
à l'instant de sonnerie de Rousseau qui
avait donc déballé sur un plateau télé
les accusations dont on faisait l'objet
Julien Bayou est-ce qu'elles prennent
trop de place aujourd'hui les féministes
non je dis pas ça je
il y a un mouvement vous dites féministe
je suis pas sûr que ce soit le vrai mot
mais en tout cas de féminisme radical
c'est à dire agressif qui
dans ces attitudes laisse croire que les
femmes et les hommes ne peuvent pas
vivre ensemble elle disent on dénonce
des violences et moi je crois le
contraire je pense que
c'est pas toujours formidable les hommes
c'est d'ailleurs pas toujours formidable
les femmes non plus
je pense qu'il y a
en effet une
une manière de vivre ensemble à trouver
qui soit respectueuse et si possible
affectueuse et cependant je ne crois pas
que la société de l'avenir doivent se
structurer sur la démolition des uns les
hommes par les autres les femmes
réciproquement je ne crois pas c'est
tout le sens de la société ou de la
civilisation que nous avons construite
depuis
huitièmes je ne crois pas que
on puisse bâtir une société sur la
domination des uns par les autres
regardez ce qui se passe en Iran
vous avez aujourd'hui un mouvement
absolument admirable de courage
de femmes qui parce qu'elles ont vu
l'une des leurs l'une de leurs jeunes
sœurs 21 ou 22 ans tués par la police
parce qu'on voyait ses cheveux à peu
près si vos informations sont justes
et vous avez des milliers de femmes qui
viennent braver cette autorité
dictatoriale en disant nous nous ne
sommes pas réductibles à notre voie nous
ne sommes pas on ne peut pas nous
ramener à cette condition là où il
faudrait qu'on se cache pour échapper au
désirant
maintenant vous voulez dire quoi quand
vous quand vous parlez de l'Iran que le
vrai patriarcat il est là-bas et pas ici
oui bien sûr mais mais
sans doute le le
je crois que l'espèce humaine est faible
et dans l'espèce humaine les hommes
peut-être ont leur faiblesse
particulière et les femmes aussi mais le
vrai combat aujourd'hui
regardez ce qui se passe en Afghanistan
on a interdit aux femmes de sortir et
aux jeunes filles et aux petites filles
de recevoir l'éducation d'aller à
l'école
pour l'émancipation
ça c'est un combat là c'est quelque
chose d'absolument majeur et je c'est
vrai que
dans le cas cathédra ou dans le cas
Julien maillot pour moi c'est pas aussi
fort
il est nécessaire de trancher contre les
violences mais quand on n'a pas
d'éléments de non seulement de preuve
mais de précision faire de la télévision
le tribunal universel ou des réseaux
sociaux le tribunal universel sur lequel
on va proposer que soit
mise en accusation condamnée et éjecter
de la vie publique
sans preuve et sans accusation il y a
quelque chose qui moi me rend ne me rend
pas heureux François bayrouilla tout
juste huit jours vous avez lancé un
avertissement gouvernement en disant que
s'il dégainait un amendement dans le
projet de financement de la Sécu pour
faire passer la réforme des retraites ce
serait un passage en force d'un mot qui
a fait la une de tous les médias pendant
48 heures est-ce que vous avez été
entendu ou non par Emmanuel Macron dans
le saura cette semaine comme la première
ministre Elisabeth borne qui est venu
devant de journée parlementaire l'a dit
Emmanuel Macron ne vous a pas répondu
nous n'avait pas parlé depuis ce on se
voit cette semaine et donc depuis 8
jours il a pas plusieurs
on échange très très souvent sur ces
sujets là depuis longtemps
et là vous y êtes
exprimé lui-même que la méthode devait
changer sur les grandes réformes du pays
sur la réforme des retraites je peux
signer la déclaration qu'il faut aller
vite
ce que j'ai dit ce week-end et que je
pense depuis longtemps
le président de la République s'est fait
lire sur cette promesse que
on a les désormais préparer les
décisions par une réflexion partagée ce
qu'il a appelé le Conseil national de la
refondation avec toutes les forces du
pays
vous la connaissez c'est passer par un
amendement dans le dans le projet de loi
de finances de la sécurité sociale ça
c'est pas la concertation c'est parce
que vous venez de dire à l'instant et
pourtant c'est sur la table encore
laissez-moi laissez-moi pour suivre ma
réflexion je pense que
précisément quand une réforme est
difficile il faut que les Français
soient associés à son élaboration
aujourd'hui il n'y a personne en France
qui est une idée claire et même pas vous
des chiffres de la retraite
des rapports différents des des analyses
différentes les individus il faut les
indices les régimes sont équilibrés j'ai
envie de dire tu parles et les autres
disent il faut à tout prix tout de suite
passer à des âges de retraite qui sont
pour beaucoup de Français quelque chose
de très perturbant sauf que c'est le
débat Françoise
Gabriel Attal hier le ministre des
comptes publics qui dit la question
n'est plus d'équilibrer le système
aujourd'hui la question de cette réforme
c'est il faut la faire pour trouver
l'argent pour augmenter les enseignants
pour baisser on n'est plus dans un débat
d'équilibre attendez qui n'est plus le
gouvernement
excusez-moi le
l'engagement c'est bien de trouver pour
les contes des régimes de retraite un
équilibre qui permet d'envisager à
l'avenir qu'on puisse continuer à payer
les pensions c'est parce Gabriel Attal
oui c'est ce que je dis moi
bonsoir devant des difficultés
budgétaires c'est indiscutable c'est un
sujet à traiter en soi
les retraites n'ont pas pour vertu
principale ou le rééquilibrage des
retraites n'a pas pour vertu principal
de redresser le budget de l'État elle a
pour vertu principale de rendre dans le
temps
crédible le paiement des pensions de
retraite et à mes yeux aujourd'hui ça
n'est pas garanti c'est la raison pour
laquelle j'ai proposé qu'on est enfin je
propose
à titre de citoyens et un peu aussi en
tant que engagé dans
cette dans ce projet de conseil national
de la refondation et un peu aussi au
titre du plan mais tout ça c'est la même
chose c'est des réflexions de citoyens
je propose que on puisse mettre sur la
table la réalité des chiffres
c'est vrai que l'état donne plusieurs
dizaines de milliards par an pour
équilibrer les retraites c'est pas les
retraites qui s'équilibrent elles-mêmes
et donc d'une certaine manière ces deux
questions sont liées c'est
il n'est pas juste comme des marches de
dire les retraites c'est pour le budget
de l'État il faut qu'il soit la méthode
François Bayrou si ça passe par un
amendement dans le PLFSS le projet de
financement de la sécurité sociale les
députés du modem ne le vôtres ne
voteront pas mais ils n'auront pas à le
voter parce que c'est ce serait un 49-3
si c'est un 49-3 il y a pas de vote mais
vous voterez la censure non sûrement pas
on va pas vous pouvez rien faire on va
pas casser la maison on va pas couler le
bateau
ne dites pas ça parce que je crois
exactement le contraire il se passera
quoi je pense que le gouvernement
l'exécutif le président de la République
ont à l'esprit
qui se passe et peut se passer dans
l'esprit public dans l'esprit de
pourquoi parce que dans cette affaire il
y a pas seulement la réforme des
retraites il y a la méthode de la
réforme tout court sur tous les grands
sujets nous avons un très grand problème
d'école d'éducation nationale qui me
tient particulièrement à cœur nous avons
un très grand problème dans le monde de
la santé nous avons un problème avec les
comptes publics nous avons un problème
avec l'efficacité en force ça va être le
feu dans la rue ce n'est pas seulement
ce que je dis s'il cette méthode était
choisie de passer
sans préparation si cette méthode était
choisie ça voudrait dire que on n'a pas
changé de méthode sur les réformes au
sens large du terme et d'ailleurs vous
les journalistes et les citoyens qui
nous écoutent ils ne croiront plus ce
qu'on dit mais du coup ce serait sans
vous le CNR
où vous continueriez tout de même
diriger je pense que le je pense que si
on choisissait cette méthode ce que je
ne crois pas je suis
persuadé que que la réflexion va
conduire à une démarche plus équilibrée
mais si je pense que le CNR serait
compromis le
tous les syndicats
présents au CNR et qui ont c'était une
réunion formidable tous ceux qui étaient
pourront vous le confirmer il s'est
passé quelque chose mais il s'est passé
quelque chose à condition que tout le
monde reste autour de la table si les si
les syndicats s'en vont je crains que je
crains que l'avenir du CNR ne soit
compromis la réponse mercredi soir à
l'Élysée ou c'est ça Emmanuel Macron
reçoit l'ensemble des chefs de partie de
la majorité dont vous François Bayrou
8h52 nous sommes terriblement en retard
le fil info avec Kevin dufresh on
poursuit juste après
le prix du paquet de cigarettes va
augmenter comme l'inflation annonce
d'Elizabeth borne ce matin invité de B
bmtv la première ministre évoque
également la réforme des retraites
prioritaires selon ces mots elle promet
la recherche du compromis sans exclure
l'utilisation du 49-3 Elizabeth borne
qui affirme que la France sera attentive
au respect des droits humains et de
l'avortement en Italie après la victoire
de la coalition de droite et d'extrême
droite 43% des voix aux élections
législatives selon des résultats
partiels Julien Bayou n'est plus
secrétaire national d'Europe Écologie
Les Verts annonce dans un communiqué ce
matin il a démissionné alors qu'il est
mis en cause par une ancienne compagne
pour des violences psychologiques selon
sa collègue députée Sandrine Rousseau la
situation est intenable écrit Julien
Bayou qui dit que les fées qui lui sont
reprochés ne lui ont pas été présentés
ni rassurante ni rassurer à 55 jours de
la Coupe du Monde l'équipe de France de
football c'est incliné hier soir au
Danemark 2-0 c'était le dernier match
des Bleus avant leur rentrée Au Lys en
lice au Qatar
France Info
[Musique]
le 8 30 France Info Salia brachia Marc
Fauvel François Bayrou vers une nouvelle
augmentation des tarifs des péages les
sociétés d'autoroute ont évoqué une
hausse et Allan jusqu'à 8 % elles
expliquent qu'elles aussi elles sont
soumises à l'inflation sur les travaux
vous vous étiez contre la privatisation
des autoroutes il y a quelques années
vous dites quoi maintenant on les laisse
faire on peut rien faire
j'étais contre la privatisation des
autoroutes et j'étais tout seul ou
presque contre la privatisation je suis
même aller au Conseil d'État à titre
personnel j'ai acheté une action moi
j'ai jamais eu aucune action de rien
j'ai acheté une action de chacune des
sociétés d'autoroutes de l'époque pour
pouvoir aller au Conseil d'État
contester cette privatisation
et j'ai dit dès ce jour-là que c'était
un allé sans retour parce que comme vous
savez il y a un principe de droit si
vous nationalisez quelque chose il faut
rembourser les propriétaires on estime
la valeur du bien nationalisé c'est ce
qui s'est passé en 80 ça d'ailleurs
rendu riche beaucoup de milliardaires la
décision de François Mitterrand
de nationaliser les banques et les
grandes sociétés a rendu riche beaucoup
de propriétaires oui
plus de 15 milliards donc quels sont les
leviers du gouvernement pour réduire un
peu la facture des automobilistes
ouvrir des discussions avec des sociétés
d'autoroute et se servir de tous les
moyens je vais employer des mots gentils
de persuasion
que dans l'état dispose en face de ces
sociétés là et je n'arrive pas à croire
qu'il n'y ait pas des possibilités
réglementaires de ne pas laisser
exploser le prix des péages comme ça
Ségolène Royal avait tenté le coup il y
a quelques années en gelant je crois que
c'était en 2015 les tarifs des
autoroutes résultat la justice à passer
derrière non seulement les
automobilistes ont payé l'augmentation
sur les années suivantes mais sera leur
a même coûté encore un peu plus cher si
les tarifs
comme une mauvaise décision
mal pensé démagogique
peut entraîner des conséquences pendant
plusieurs décennies c'est ce que nous
sommes en train de vivre c'est la raison
pour laquelle j'ai toujours mis en garde
en vain contre l'allongement perpétuel
des concessions d'une des solutions
dans une dizaine d'années les autoroutes
ce serait d'accorder encore un deux ou
trois ans de plus en concession et en
échange de limiter c'est une bonne
solution on ne fait que pousser le
problème c'est perpétuellement la
démarche d'un certain nombre de ces
sociétés d'autoroute et là et la
faiblesse de l'État
François bayrouot alors qu'il a annoncé
la mobilisation de 300 000 réservistes
Vladimir Poutine a aussi durci les
peines contre les déserteurs jusqu'à 10
ans de prison pour les militaires qui
refusent de combattre est-ce qu'il faut
accueillir les déserteurs russes qu'ils
soient militaires ou pas comme va le
faire l'Allemagne par exemple je suis
d'accord je pense qu'on a un devoir
d'asile
chaque fois que un événement très grave
et causé par un état est indiscutable
que ces Poutine et lui seul qui a décidé
de cette guerre
d'annexion de l'Ukraine
d'occupation et d'annexion de l'Ukraine
chaque fois qu'il y a des objecteurs de
conscience
à l'intérieur de ces états le devoir des
pays démocratiques et de les accueillir
les déserteurs uniquement où tous ceux
qui aujourd'hui fuient le régime on voit
la frontière entre la Russie et la
Finlande et la dernière frontière
terrestre ouverte entre la Russie et
l'Europe que des gens qui se présentent
là ne sont pas des hommes en âge d'aller
combattre il faut que il faut qu'on que
les que les États démocratiques et
notamment ceux de l'Union européenne en
parle entre eux c'était décisions qu'il
faut prendre ensemble et pas qu'il faut
prendre séparément d'après les qu'il
faut le plus possible prendre ensemble
en évitant le plus possible d'aller
prendre séparément d'après les services
les services secrets américain la Russie
aurait versé près 300 millions de
dollars depuis 2014 à des candidats ou
partie étrangers pour essayer
d'influencer d'influencer les élections
l'ex ambassadeur de France en Russie
Jean Maurice Ripert a affirmé que des
politiques français d'un certain bord
avait aussi perçu des sommes d'argent
est-ce qu'il faut ouvrir une commission
d'enquête il faut faire la lumière sur
tout ça il y a pas besoin d'une
commission d'enquête normalement c'est
fait là sont des délits et même
probablement des crimes contre l'État la
justice donc la justice et la police les
enquêtes doivent se dérouler sur ce
point s'il n'y avait aucune réponse
alors des commissions d'enquêtes mais je
ne crois pas que les commissions
d'enquête doivent être la première
réponse il faut que il faut qu'on se
saisisse de ces choses là est-ce qu'il y
a eu est-ce que c'est avéré
par intuition je dirais probablement que
oui pour avoir vous savez été moi-même
autrefois par intuition ça veut dire
quoi par intuition oui j'ai pas de
preuve mais je pense que c'est ça que ça
veut dire par intuition merci François
on a plus le temps je suis désolé ça
mériterait de d'en parler un tout petit
peu plus mais voilà merci à vous bonne
journée
[Musique]